حنان مطاوع 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
بسرعه ومن غير تفكير دور صنع اسمك
ساره ما حننظر اكثر شيء يفشل في او يفشل
الحب
الاعتياد
صفه اكتسبتيها من والدتك الفنانه سهير
المرشدي وصفه من والدك الراحل الفنان كرم
مطاوع من بابا الله يرحمه
المثابره واني اعرف اقول لا
حتى لو انا محتاجه اقول اه ماما اعتقد
بر الاقربون والعيله والحميميه هل وجدت
موهبه حنان مطاوع التقدير اللي بتستحقه
الحمد لله
مره في مره كده بعد يوم مين هي نجمه تجيلك
الاولى من وجهه نظرك كثير
منى زكي هي سبقاني
هند صبري برده سابقاني منه شلبي
اعتقد من ابرزهم بس في ناس تانيه طالعه
برضه متى تصيب النجوميه الفنان بالجنون او
الغرور
لما يبقى مش متزن ولما يبقى مش عارف ان كل
شيء الا زوال دور بتحلمي بتقديمه
مصر القديم عالم المصري القديم لانه شايف
فرعوني مثلا طيب حاولتي وانت بتكبري انه
الناس ما تعرف انه اهلك فنانين مشهورين
وعانتي رغباتهم عشان تشقي طريق بنفسك هل
اليوم انت ندمانه كان مستاهل الموضوع اه
اوكي اكثر شيء تغير فيك بعد ولاده بنتك
اماليا كل حاجه كل حاجه كل حاجه كل حاجه
حبيت الدنيا اكتر حبيت ان انا اعيش اكثر
بقى فارق معي ان انا اعيش عشانها دور
ندمتي عليه
مش هقول اسمه طبعا عشان صناعه بس في مثلا
اثنين ثلاثه مش حباهم بس مش بسببي بسبب
انه الفن عمل جماعي انت بتبقي داخله
متخيله انما هنا يا اما هناك وفي الاخر حد
هو اللي بيبوظ لك الحكايه كلها طب قولي
اسم اوكي طيب اكبر تاثير الانفصال والديك
عليك
[موسيقى]
الصلابه اوكي تاثير ايجابي يعني اوكي اكثر
عيب يزعجك في زوجك
التدخين اوكي لو عندك مشكله مين اول وحده
ممكن تلجا الى في الوسط الفني ريهام عبد
الغفور من واحد لعشره قديش بتعاني من
الوسواس قهري في موضوع النظافه
[ضحك]
ايش اهم نصيحه توجهيها لنفسك لو رجع فيك
الزمن
ما تقلقيش كله جاي
ليش السينما مش صحبه معاكي هي فين السينما
ايه يا ساره ايه فين السينما يا ساره اوكي
عيني حتى ما بيعجبك اللي بيتقدم حاليا لا
في حاجات بتقدم لطيفه بس في الاخر هي ندره
يعني فين ايام ما كنا بنعمل مثلا 50 فيلم
في السنه انت بتعملي كم دلوقتي
طيب ليش لما بتتخانجي بتستخدم اللغه
العربيه الفصحى
من بدايه السؤال عارفه حتكملي تقولي علشان
عشان بلاقي فيها
المعنى اللي انا عايزه اقوله
بانك تقدري توبخي اللي قدامك من غير ما
تجرحيين من غير ما تلفظي الفاظ نابيه او
انك تتدني بالحوار فهو تهزيء بس ايش به هو
تهذيب
طيب صفه فيكي نفسك ما تورثيها لبنتك الكسل
من قبل ما افكر العصبيه مع اني انا تعصب
على الاخر قد ما انا بتعصب قوه القوه
الدربكه درب نفسك
وببين دايما الهدوء عند الموضوع مستنينا
اهلا مين الفنان اللي نفسك تشتغلي معه
في واحد كده قولي نفسك خالد النبوي منى
زكي اوكي خلاص كفايه
البعض بيقول انك متخصصه في ادوار النكد
كيف تردي يا جماله يا جماله ههه
الست
اه مطحونه مطحونه والراجل كمان على فكره
يعني انا شايفه انه الاثنين مطحونين بس هو
مجتمع
بيكيل بكيلين شويه صح اوكي لو انطلب منك
سيفي لك انت في ثلاثه ادوار بس تختاري اي
ثلاثه ادوار
مما عملت من اللي انت عملتيه
هذا المساء دور عبله سخيه
[موسيقى]
حلاوه الدنيا
اختيار حلو جدا اوكي سؤال نفسك من زمان اي
اعلامي يسالك هو ومن سالتيه
وحياتك مفكره ولا ما عندك شيء تحسي نفسي
اسالوني السؤال ده
هي المشكله في المباغته انك تساليني
السؤال ايه انتوهي الاجابه ايوه
يمكن لو مخمخت حاجه اقول لك فعلا ما حدش
سالني السؤال ده قبل كده طيب خلاص خليني
ابدلك السؤال ده بتحبيني
[ضحك]
والله شكرا شفتي خلصنا لا يا شيخ والله
العظيم ابص لك ولا لا لا يا شيخ دول 25
ولا سبعه
لازم 25 شيخة والله العظيم
ايه ده اه شفتي ولا فيه اي شيء ده ده مفيش
حاجه فعلا